[Music]
in four women news submitted by hey
ladies
buses at Doritos have revealed their to
launch a new lady friendly version of
the snack I'm interested in landing
chips the CEO of PepsiCo she was
claiming that research has found that
women don't like crunching loudly on the
chip so we're talking about specifically
Doritos here Pepsi Cola owns Doritos oh
my god it's like a gala Polly you just
say Pepsi Cola Pepsi Pepsi Cola Pepsi
company but PepsiCo I'm assuming is
Pepsi Cola right our company yeah Cola
yes it is to answer your question yes
Pepsi's full name is Pepsi Cola yep
every time I hear call all I think about
is Coke because Cola was around and that
like a generic brand of Cola you could
find at the store like RC Cola Cola is a
flavor yeah it's a flavor of Cola look
over it yeah it's a little Kona it's
like the McMuffin it's not a McMuffin
barks did you know that depending on
what part of the US you live in you say
different words yeah pop soda and coke
Cola
I don't friend anybody that says pop
sound like a three-year-old say that's
me assumption here's some pop no first
of all you're 50 years old but Coca Cola
tastes way better than Pepsi they had
that extra caramel like Coca Cola to
this guy I was a Pepsi person until bar
yeah this will started drinking coke
every day in front of me with all
daily Kona ice to the top and I was like
I gotta try it how he does it it's such
an influencer there's the way he drinks
coke is like he's never had liquid in
his life around a cup with coke and then
put milk in it as a ghetto root beer
float when I was a waitress cocaine milk
yeah just like full of coke and then put
like milk on the table that was don't
it's like a ghetto root beer float we
were just like weird poor waiters and
like what can we get away with what
we're on our ships stories of Nikki
leave other people I don't have a real
root beer float so I was 17
Oh just kidding so the CEO here she was
just pretty much saying that women don't
like the loud crunch and that we don't
like to lick our fingers or or get the
crumbs out of the what the [ __ ] I do all
of me too I just put a blanket over
women and be like Oh women because of me
and I'm a women and I speak for all
women maybe this is our grandma if I
could picture my grandma eating this way
I mean she yeah she's like a lady yeah
my grandma's like which though she wants
a soggy chip no so we're sua saying here
is that they're developing products like
lady like lady friendly products so then
this went viral
what lady Doritos are you for real but
the crunch is like the best part is I
like hearing it - yeah I like fuller I'm
like get all the seasoning at the bottom
and look at the fingers maybe you turn
the bag inside out you know what I used
to do I used to go like this lick my
finger so that it's already wet before I
go inside we're just talking about lady
[ __ ] maybe you're not ladies do you yes
we're not lady did you have girlfriends
growing up because I didn't having
girlfriends growing up so that could be
a big part of it I did yeah I was
usually like the guy of the group okay I
had maybe she's just outdated then like
she thinks that leave my mom
see I told you it's our moms and Grandma
maybe there's an age demographic of
ladies that she's talking about old
farts what you got just favorite Dorito
flavor original all day second is rayon
what's the original what's original
that's not your cheese that's not your
cheese flavor
there's no they have no original your
mom probably just bought that the most
and uh this is Mexican enough wait so
they came out with multiple flavors I'm
not your cheese and chlorin number one
you know how I hate Taco Bell but then
if I do get it Cool Ranch Doritos how
can you hate Taco Bell because they're
my rival you what I like I like Taco
Bell
you're a monster okay but del tacos the
best yeah no idea how many like sponsor
JK films Davis of comedies Gina darling
is on freaking what's it called the Del
Taco page now we just switched over [ __ ]
McDonald's even though I eat you we're
talking about Taco Bell I know came out
of nowhere
del Taco tweet sent tweets me and
follows me we know you say it every
single time from every time we get it
they [ __ ] love you do you guys have
celebrities following you I have all
their numbers
Doritos tweeted me on the Super Bowl a
couple years ago that's dope Doritos
yeah Doritos yeah and it's relevant more
relevant than your Del Taco get out of
here
I like them are they paying you no then
do you like them no it doesn't matter
because that's how you know it's
authentic it's from the heart
I had no sell out high okay sell out of
hell what was it two months ago two
months ago that's not loyalty bro hey
you know you know what else isn't oil
tea I don't know what you were doing
shaky and fell very inappropriate
pornhub tweeted me multiple times with a
tie to stop watching this [ __ ]
I got a bunch of tweets because pornhub
had a picture of me in an ad on their
site yeah because there's a gift that
someone made of me going like this in a
video as a joke
no they just but it was like hot girls
ready to suck dick and it's me again
baby like and it's like that video was
so innocent well where is this gift when
they tweeted me it was so odd too cuz I
didn't like Hobby approached me they're
like hey man we'll give you a whole
bunch of free porn Baba it's better
first of all [ __ ] it was like if I if I
like retweet or did something with them
as like this is a very awkward and open
Brandi privately or something but it was
just really weird I didn't know jealous
because you never talk about porn on JK
news and I do choose it's not sounding
so thirsty dude you already know that
brands are like girls
yeah you gotta caress them you gotta
boost their ego you got to back off
enough but still show that you're
interested I just want to work with
people that I love so back to the lady
doritos thing so that went like all
crazy people were tweeting at them like
really like what's next right all these
like women product like for women I know
you know I hate lady Legos what the [ __ ]
they're Legos but they're pink and
yellow have you seen the pen the big
four women
no you just pink and purple again I get
it if it's like this is pink for breast
cancer you know like and some of the
proceeds go to helping women I get that
but I don't get the like this shit's the
same we're just making it pink and
calling it lady whatever's I honestly
don't care if they do that I'm like
whatever that's what you think fine just
don't like if they start charging more
for it than like [ __ ] pink tax but
who's fighting for these products like
we need this we need more female
versions of this comes like it's men
trying to be like inclusive with the
women but instead of doing that they
were like the other way segregating what
if it's a bunch of women and the
Executive Board and they're like we need
to do this and they're like yeah it just
doesn't communicate with the rest
because I seriously doubt as men doing
dudes dudes are a soul tunnel-vision
they don't know that they're [ __ ] up
or they don't know that they're
excluding people yeah so I think it's
somewhat I don't know who the group is
that's fighting hey we need this for
women this for women and then guys like
oh sure we are [ __ ] up yeah we should
make them you know though I literally
stopped eating Carl's jr. because of
their ads because I was so annoyed by
like how they only market to men I guess
the Carl's jr. everyday and then I was
just so bad at their ads I was like [ __ ]
this place yeah when they just kept
eating like the girl at the hot girl we
just it was that one and then there was
one that was like uh there was one we're
like the guys would be at a grocery
store and not know what to pick and
they're like Carl's jr. for men it's
like women don't know what to eat and
it's like they do make men look [ __ ]
dumb they do it also makes me want to
eat Carl's jr. I like Carl's jr. though
Carl's jr. is the one where the burger
comes down out of nowhere yeah yeah
there's always a girl to like and in the
ketchup oh yeah it looks like she's like
eating conversation I may have
celebrities sometimes do it the sound
design is awesome like right when that
burger falls up like I leave me one of
those I know and then you order it you
get it and it's so [ __ ] tragedy like
this thing you know what was dope though
when they came out with their six dollar
burger and it was like that thick
[ __ ] patty that [ __ ] was tight yep
and in the me actually tastes like smoke
a little bit because horrible [ __ ] with
it dude okay so it works on men I get if
it said made for women the the Chris cut
fries alone the seasoned waffle fries
that [ __ ] alone is good enough
jack-in-the-box is the word that
competitor curly fries yeah I like those
[ __ ] your fries Carl's jr. so was this
lady getting a bunch of [ __ ] from a
bunch of women or just in general they
were like [ __ ] you woman no I wasn't
really the CEO is more Doritos so then
Doritos and are there outraged women
they said we already have Doritos for
women they're called Doritos and I love
you
the Doritos brand went against the lady
the CEO know so what happened here was
like apparently she was talking about
products like like packaging Doritos and
a more like wafer [ __ ] females to
open it cuz we're dumb no are like
that's a good idea shut up
geo bag they didn't like handbags cuz
she was like yeah women love to carry
snacks in their purses so we're gonna I
don't even have a [ __ ] purse [ __ ] you
I've never heard of like someone being
like you know what I like Doritos you
know what I don't like the crunch no I
don't like all this seasoning eat a
freaking tortilla chip then just like
have a tortilla chip or a tortilla bread
a tortilla so it doesn't crunch corn
tortilla
yeah they later came out saying like no
like you know they everyone
misinterpreted what she was trying to
say so movie trying to say then yeah
what a war started oh but everything she
said was pretty [ __ ] clear to me she
[ __ ] up she just be like I'm stupid
actually I was talking about myself and
I realized I'm the only one in the world
like this I feel like shoot like that
was the one product of PepsiCo that she
didn't like and she's like how could I
change this so I could represent it and
like it she [ __ ] that bad idea
[Music]